[Musique]
nous
il
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui
nous nous consacrons à un écrivain qui
va nous parler d'un célèbre versailles
et à savoir l'eau 16 auquel il il
consacra les on dit deux fois consacre
un livre qui s'appelle le roi qui
voulaient voir la mer voilà gérard de
cortanze bonjour oui alors merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation parce qu'on
va parler d'un livre absolument
passionnant qui détonne un peu dans dont
le petit fond de l'histoire le petit
rond l'histoire habituelle
déjà pour un peu mieux vous connaître
vous êtes à la fois éditeur et auteur de
nombreux ouvrages
jusqu'ici c'est vrai jusque là c'est
vrai est-ce que vous pouvez nous citer
deux trois livres que vous avez écrit
qui vous tiennent à coeur à part celui
ci bien sûr qu'elle dernier tous les
livres sur sur frida kahlo le guernic
s'est plaisamment de cueillir à cannes
qui raconte l'histoire
c'est extraordinaire entre entre frida
kahlo et trotsky qui sont tombés
amoureux contre ce qui est arrivé au
mexique en 37 et puis j'ai une petite
tendresse pour un aller qui s'appelle
indigo les tisanes leur paraître dans la
collection libretto chez phébus indigo
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui a le
visage bleu ça se passe en en savoie ou
moment la savoie va devenir françaises
et italiennes à savoir est ce cet homme
qui a le visage bleu et est accusé de
tous les malheurs de la terre tout
simplement parce qu'il a vu visage bleu
d'accord bon écoute et on pourrait
passer des heures à willy ronis voilà
c'est ça donc on va aller directement
dans le vif du sujet à savoir ce livre
là qui vient de sortir donc le roi qui
voulaient voir la mer donc chez albin
michel bien évidemment votre maison
d'édition et là où vous travaillez aussi
en celui qui dort voilà et vous citez
louis saez sur la couverture vous dites
cette masse enfin vous écrivez cette
masse d'eau mystérieuse donne une idée
de l'immensité du monde la voir c'est
mon rêve d'enfant qui se réalise voilà
alors déjà vu ce que faisait louis et
parce que vous disiez vous pouvez vous
citer louis saez en fait c'est le
principe de la de la littérature c'est à
dire que louis saez n'a jamais prononcé
cette phrase mais bien entendu il aurait
pu la halle a prononcé un cessez le
weekend argus c'est la situation des
acacias sa quête au début c'est à dire
en fait on atteint à la vérité
romanesque parlement seront joués et moi
je suis persuadé que cette phrase
évidemment il a prononcé d'accord donc
c'est tout le coeur du livre en fait oui
se comprend mais qu'il est solide et on
dirait presque un journal intime comme
si louis saez écrivait jour par jour
lui-même quoi vous êtes vraiment mis
dans sa peau si oui alors c'est le point
de départ du livre et les points départ
du livre voilà c'est pas question j'ai
toujours été fasciné par l'histoire de
ce petit garçon qui monte sur les
terrasses du château de versailles
pour essayer de te trouver de quel côté
se trouve la mer
je trouve ça je suis pas très poétique
une sorte de
tout ça très beau enfin cette hépatite x
il ya plus un peu pathétique et donc je
voulais raconter l'histoire de ce roi
qui un jour décide d'aller à cherbourg
alors il prend le prétexte de des
chantiers de l'homme de cherbourg qui
l'a initié d'ailleurs qui commence pour
en réalité aller voir cette mère qu'il
n'a pas vu qui depuis qu'il était enfant
les ai vus il n'a jamais vu il n'est
jamais monté sur un bateau n'a jamais
dépassé rambouillet voilà alors que
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît mais
parfaitement tout ce qui touche à la mer
c'est à dire les les bateaux le les
marées les vents les voyages et les
bibliothèques de 45 me de volume autour
de autour de tout ça et
ça c'était le premier point c'est à dire
qu'on va leur parler de ce voyage parler
et parler d'homme de la normandie met le
deuxième point et ça c'est quelque chose
que comment dire qui tu es venu au fur
et à mesure de l'écriture du livre et
surtout de la de du travail de lecture
que j'ai effectué de recherche c'est à
l'arrivée c'est une c c'est devenu une
réhabilitation de louis saez c'est à
dire que on s'aperçoit que ce que ce roi
qui passe d'abord pour pour 1,1
grassouillet qui fait qu'il fut un mètre
90 et donc il ya plein de choses comme
un songe le deuxième mensonge on en fait
un imbécile heureux ou pas heureux je ne
sais pas mais tous est il que whip à 13
euros exactement toujours est il que cet
enfant qui est né comment dire qui était
entouré durant toute son enfance et de
l'essence de mort ses parents sont morts
mon frère est mort et c'est donc il vit
dans cette ambiance mortifère
on en fait un imbécile mais c'est tout
sauf en abyssinie il parle cinq langues
îles cook navires dans le tas dans le
texte il travie diffuse david yum il est
capable de terroriser les théories de
l'air sur la mécanique des fluides c'est
quelqu'un qui est comment dire qu'il ya
un laboratoire de chimie quand on quand
on explique qu'il est qu'il est
passionné par la serrurerie oui mais là
c'est
l'horlogerie ça n'a rien de ridicule
parce que toute la les avancées
techniques du xviiie naissent de ces de
ces mouvements très précis d'horloger de
serrurerie c'est un véritable sens il
est il est totalement en avant sur son
texte et moi j'ai trouvé une formule
jeudi en fait que les révolutionnaires
en fait sont des hommes du passé et
l'homme du futur celui qui a vraiment
compris son temps qui n'a pas pu
appliquer ces réformes
mais qui le vrai révolutionnaire c'est
luis saez est il le nom de réformes
qu'il a effectuée en si peu de temps
mais oui et il est mort il est mort
très jeune
j'aime à dire aussi que s'il avait vécu
aussi longtemps que son grand père eh
bien il serait mort en 1831 ce qui est
fou voilà donc et tout est dit avec ça
est ce que vous savez par exemple je
ferai trois émissions pour en parler
est-ce que vous sait par exemple que il
a 20 ans la première mesure qu'il
envisage de faire voter évidemment la
mesure ne va pas abouti vous allez
comprendre pourquoi il veut abolir
l'esclavagé ni oui mais c'est
extraordinaire on le sait qu'il a voulu
accueillir d'espionnage non qu'on était
à prévoir les votre lit quand mélenchon
veut à nantes qu'est ce qu'il fait il
veut déboulonner les statues louis saez
studio en disant que c'était un énorme
malentendu mais c'est un énorme avec le
map mais seul il m'a remué
ce qui est absolument passionnant c'est
que ce roi en fait il est il est très
très éloignées comme un et du clergé et
du et de la noblesse voilà et de la cour
autour de versailles ce qui cela il est
proche du peuple voilà alors c'est ça
qui est très important dans ce voyage
qui dure 4 4 saint geours finalement
tout ce que vous dites là on le ressent
à travers ce fameux voyage donc moi je
vais juste lire une toute petite phrase
qui donne un peu son état d'esprit avant
avant de partir il dit enfin vous dit en
réalité il n'en pouvait plus de
versailles de seo croupissante qui
empestait de septfontaines envasé tout
l'été de ce parc infesté de mouches et
de moustiques l'hiver ce n'était guère
mieux tout en bruit a glacé en courant
d'air sifflant dans toutes les pièces en
au-dessus mines et répondent à une
chaleur d'enfer avant de s'éteindre et
tous ses courtisans et leurs katas voilà
donc notre ami louis saez il est donc
ils rêvent de voir la mer donc ici ce il
se donne ce prétexte d'aller voir la
rade de cherbourg et de la la sphère de
mettre les travaux en place 3d
surveiller voilà par rapport aux
invasions des anglais où il sur presque
calonne oui enfin n'oubliez pas que
lorsqu'il a récupéré la marine française
héritée de louis 15 c'est une marine qui
est totalement exemple oui par les
anglais en six ans
les français sur une quarantaine de la
ville les enfants dont six en voilà et
la marine françaises
il ya plus de deux fils y est il ya
pratiquement pas de marins les bateaux
sont obsolètes et lui en très très peu
de temps il va en faire pratiquement la
première marine du monde déjà il va
aider les états unis à se libérer du
joug anglais grâce à la marine et c'est
là il ya un déclic qui se perd c'est à
dire au fond la marine française peut
battre la marine anglaise c'est pour ça
que cherbourg il veut construire une
rade et il construit des rades pour
protéger sa la marine qui en train de se
démener pour protéger ces bateaux pour
les mettre à l'abri si simplement dans
le sud de la france la face atlantique
et toute la face en face de la qui fait
face à d'énormes entreprenons votre
voyage ou un cerveau alors il est dans
son carrosse il est il est accompagné
par trois aristocrate qui sont ces
conseillers qui commencent eux un petit
peu à lui sortir par le nez si vous me
permettez moi j'étais sûr parce que
finalement comme vous disiez il se rend
compte que ces aristocrates ne voient
que leurs intérêts et que actuellement
toutes les mesures humanitaires que vous
16 appris the who veut prendre eux ça ne
les arrange pas du tout ça juste raidie
que alors quand il explique qu'il veut
un lit par malade à l'hôpital un hôpital
spécialisé pour les enfants mal à
atteindre des choses très très très
humani théâtre est généreux ce genre il
aime son peuple et il se dit un bon roi
doit tout faire pour son peuple enfin il
ya une citation j'ai plus trop ce que
c'est alors ça qu'ils vont la vivre elle
qui est tiré de ses réflexions et ses
dents dans ses réflexions d'ailleurs que
tout le monde ne peut lire et je ne
comprends pas qu'on qu'on ne parle pas
assez de ça dans ses réflexions il il
invente le concept de justice sociale en
plus et on voit que ce voyage est bien
évidemment il ya pas mal d'arrêts alors
ça j'imagine j'imagine que c'est votre
imaginaire ah non alors attendent les
jeunes femmes qui deviennent son chemin
comme des forces et à de mauvais augure
pour son bien qu'ils ont faite on voit
ces sons des années voyager au rayon
ressent à travers ce livre que ce sont
ces derniers instants de vie parce que
il est il est prévenu entre guillemets
par des sortes de femmes sorcières
c'est vous qui avez inventé mais là
encore je suis persuadé qu'il a dû les
rencontres et sélectionné lui annonce
qu'il va se passer c'est son seul voyage
il seul voyage qu'il n'était pas un
c'était lors du sacre en 75 harrah's le
dernier voyage on sait comment est ce
qu'il est il va se terminer mais ce qui
est intéressant dans dans ce voyage
c'est qu'au départ les courtisans ne
veulent absolument pas qu'il rencontre
le peuple et ça c'est à dire cesser
c'est ce qui s'est passé durant tout son
règne ils font barrage long le lez en
son palais surtout pas qu'ils aient un
contact à la jeu il ya un journaliste en
belgique j'ai fait une tournée en
belgique pour le lancer le livre qui m'a
dit une chose assez intéressante il m'a
dit qu'au fond louis saez quand il va
dans les provinces de france qu enfin
quand il vend en normandie il va à la
rencontre des gilet jaune et il ya
quelque chose de sa dedans il a écrit
quelque part et ça je le retranscris
dans le temps dans le livre il dit au
fond le clergé ses 173 milles membres la
noblesse et 250000 moi ce que je veux
faire c'est essayer de réformer le pays
pour les 26 millions de français voilà
et ça c'est nul ça n'arrange pas
tellement les pas du tout
on veut que la situation reste comme
elle est il ya aussi toute la
bourgeoisie montante qui n'a pas du tout
un week end sur cd aux mêmes privilèges
c'est à dire que c'est pas le moment qui
a touché alors que finalement lui il se
dit mais pourquoi n'ai-je pas ce fait ça
plutôt aller de région en région à la
rencontre des gens voir ce qu'ils
veulent leur donner si possible etc
alors malheureusement l'émission est
presque terminée dommage dommage mais
attendez alors pour moi ça se fait
comment ont réagi les historiens face à
votre livre est ce que c'est vraiment
une nouvelle image que vous nous donner
et je termine juste quand il refait
l'eau il est de retour à à versailles on
a l'impression qu'il a enfin à créer une
autorité qu'il avait pas vraiment à dia
qui dit assez à ses conseillers restent
dehors fichez moi la paix je ne veux pas
vous voir on va on va les virer excusez
moi je parle voilà et c'est une autorité
qu'il aurait dû avoir avant peut-être
oui c'est ça mais il n'a pas eu alors il
l'a fait parce que c'est l'avenir c'est
l'ère de la mère qui l'a bien sûr c'est
le sait le son éducation oui oui il faut
qu'il arrive à sortir de tout ça et
alors ce qui est vrai en revanche
cependant dans le livre c'est la réalité
du du voyage le nom de jours qu'a duré
le voyage le fait qu'on ne voulait pas
qu'il ya normandie parce qu'on l'a dit
les routes sont mauvaises les normands
ne parle pas français ah oui ariès 600
et langue ça c'est très important
tellement fou il faut qu'on il faut
conserver imaginez on est en 1786 ai dit
il faut conserver le patois et il faut
pas appeler ça un patois c'est une
langue il ya la langue française qui se
développe il faut la développer et
d'ailleurs il dit au fond très
visionnaire mais ce soir il faut que les
gens puissent circuler des routes soient
bonnes qu'on circus section de la langue
circulent quand il dit la langue c'est
pas les académiciens qui les font
circuler c'est des gens qui construisent
les routes c'est totalement novateur et
c'était totalement visionnaire quand il
décide de financer les recherches sur
les roses patio et spatiaux mais selon
lui elle finit mal c'est vrai mais ça
veut dire qu'il dit un jour les hommes
vont venez on est en 10 786 tout le
monde de prendre pour un fou il a été
coupé dans son élan il avait eu la bonne
idée c'était une véritable personne très
humaniste qui était alors sa re encore
plus c'est un livre très touchant en
fait parce que c'est un peu d'aidé
désespoir qui n'ont pas abouti et ça
aurait pu avoir une vie magnifique y
faire de très belles choses exactement
et ça rentre d'autant plus touchant et
poignante la scène de son guillotine
mans oui au fait c'est à dire le la
dernière scène je me demande si j'ai
écrit le tout se livrent pour la
dernière scène est absolument terrible
j'ai voulu suivre minute par minute en
temps réel et là encore il ya une une
sorte de mensonge historique de
mensonges d'état puisqu'en fait on
expliqué
qu'il avait eu peur que c'était
lamentable cette mode ils étaient
conduits et le bourreau en fait pendant
toute sa vie à ruminer cette histoire
est finalement quelques jours avant de
mourir il écrit une lettre en disant
tout ce qu'on raconte est faux là ce roi
alors moi je ne suis ni un ni royaliste
et monuments leurs chiffres
ce roi a eu a eu une attitude
remarquable je pense que c'était faut la
saluer on est vraiment passés à côté
d'un grand monarque est mort on est
d'accord jardin qu'hortense il faut lire
ce livre qui nous donne une nouvelle et
belle image 2016 est vraiment un gros
merci c'est passionnant et à très
bientôt j'espère pour un nouveau livre
oui mais le nouveau c'est un scoop ce
sera septembre c'est un livre sur frida
kahlo a très bien j'ai envie de vous
dire à bientôt alors à bientôt merci
enfin gérard de cortanze
[Musique]
donc
petit